algunas personas cuando intentan
solucionar un conflicto
eligen primero entenderse ellos mismos
y acuden a una librería
van y compra un libro de autoayuda que
les ayude un poco a solucionar ese
impasse que tienen
prefieren esto a ir con un profesional
de la salud
otros van un paso más adelante
y comprar una tarjeta con un mensaje
predeterminado de acuerdo
a esa expresión a esa emoción que
quieren transmitirle con la persona que
quieren solucionar un conflicto ese
mensaje lo escribió alguna persona que
seguramente en su vida nunca llegarán a
conocer
otras eligen un medio que no es útil
pero que es inolvidable
y es adquirir de forma legal o ilegal un
arma de fuego
para acabar con la vida de la persona o
las personas o las personas con las
cuales tiene un conflicto
de acuerdo un estudio reciente
desarrollado por las universidades de
harvard columbia y dio
determinó que 22 millones de personas en
eeuu aproximadamente el 9% de la
población adulta en este país sufre de
ira impulsiva
la idea impulsiva
trata de comportamientos violentos
desordenados
que no tienes motivo
de forma impredecible y que puede
atentar con la vida de estas personas o
con las vidas de las personas que están
a su alrededor
también el estudio arrojo
que aproximadamente 4 millones de
personas de esta población tienen fácil
acceso a las armas
generalmente estas personas acuden a
espacios públicos con sus armas
poniendo el riesgo
a las personas que están a su alrededor
nací en cali colombia mi nombre es
carlos javier libreros muñoz soy
ingeniero electrónico
en el año 2016 he elegido por el
departamento de estado de los eeuu para
ir como delegado por colombia a la
cumbre global de emprendimiento
la cumbre global de emprendimiento
reunión expertos
inversionistas y líderes en el campo de
innovación de empresas
e innovación
esta se dio en la universidad de
stanford en sillicon valley california
yo creo que todos se preguntarán lo
llaman la cumbre global de
emprendimiento en la meca de la
tecnología y desarrollo tecnológico que
ha generado los últimos grandes en las
últimas décadas grandes cambios y
grandes gallas a la sociedad
este con que fue
bueno
pues
para mí fue
algo muy motivador ver entre las
asistentes a personas reconocidas por
los sus gadgets o su tipo de innovación
estaba en los vídeos de google google
pichai estaba el siglo de linkedin
hoffman estaba el sitio de facebook
zuckerberg estaba esquí de google
hoover estaba josman también el miami y
yo a que iba no
cierto
como ingeniero electrónico soy
apasionado por la tecnología
y me gustan esas esos grandes de esas
cosas que uno lo asombra muchos amigos
familiares pensaban cuando le dije que
iba silicon valley en una cumbre no al
emprendimiento que ha sido elegido entre
7000 personas para ir
que iba a reinventar el teléfono
bueno
no fue incrementar el teléfono pero si
utilice un proceso que utiliza que desde
hace más de 50 años se aplica en
tecnología
eso es una compuerta
que trabaja con una tabla de verdad
la tabla verde indica que en esa salida
donde estás a veces solamente va a haber
un 1 si la hay la ve hay un 1 es la
única condición si hay un 0 en alguna de
las otras salidas y hay un 1 en la otra
en la unah alguna de las entradas hay un
0 y en la otra de un 1 no va a funcionar
no va a haber una salida
pero vamos a hacer un pequeño ejemplo de
cómo funciona esta tabla lógica esta
compuerta lógica amba
yo soy la única persona autorizada aquí
en este escenario para decirles por
favor saquen sus celulares listo tomen
sus celulares y vayan hasta la interfaz
que le permite usar su celular como una
linterna pero no hay que encender la luz
todavía
y listo
listo entonces yo soy la entrada
y yo le estoy diciendo lo que es todo lo
que él
le dije que vayan a sus celulares van
hasta la interfaz y todo eso listo ese
es el primer uno ahorita ustedes activen
la linterna
guau
un aplauso esto es para una foto esto es
genial genial un aplauso para ustedes
mismos no solamente para los que estamos
acá adelante
muy bien muy bien ahora así como me está
dando esa luz bueno digamos que así me
llegó la luz para crear el pañol de la
paz pero este proceso que hemos creado
de que le dije por favor vean sus
celulares manda la interfaz y ustedes
prendieron la luz así trabajó una
comportan y el resultado de esa salida
es esa luz que tenemos en el auditorio
muchas gracias ya pueden guardar sus
celulares pero asimismo con esa luz
blanca
pues a mí el blanco también me llegó en
ese proceso de creación del pañuelo de
la paz
el blanco siempre se ha utilizado las
maderas blancas cuando
queremos expresar traigo
bueno tenemos una bandera utilizamos un
pañuelo
y ahí empecé a impulsar ese
emprendimiento innovación social
haciendo honor al nombre de mi hijo juan
diego
y el pañuelo de la paz significa un
gesto de reflexión y cambio de una
persona para con otra
y viceversa y el mundo
aporta un granito de arena no silicio
todavía porque no es tecnología no es un
gadget a la paz del mundo ya la paz de
mi país
pero también rompe paradigmas de cómo
expresar amor de cómo estar en paz
con esa con plena convicción de lo que
era el paño de la paz pues participe en
la cumbre anual de emprendimiento
en esta obama nos motivó a que
creyéramos en que el mundo necesita de
nuestra creatividad energía
y talento
y que un mundo es mucho mejor cuando
estamos conectados y cuando nos
permitimos compartir ideas como lo
estamos haciendo un evento como el día
en el día de hoy
el pañuelo de la paz cómo funciona son
tres pasos reconocer positivamente una
persona comprometerse a cambiar y estar
en paz
el pañuelo es acompañado de dos tarjetas
es un pañuelo blanco están acompañados
dos tarjetas
en la cual la primera persona que tiene
esa intención le reconoce positivamente
lo que hace la otra con la cual tiene el
disgusto quiere reconciliarse y también
se compromete a cambiar en algo la
persona le envía el pañuelo con la
tarjeta pero hay una tarjeta vacía en
blanco que espera que la segunda persona
que recibe el pañuelo también le
reconozca positivamente y se comprometa
a cambiar el tercer paso pues la paz
está hecho
la paz
funciona en tres simples pasos o en tres
pasos esenciales reconocer al otro en su
diferencia
comprometerse a cambiar con el otro y
empezar esa acción que ambas personas
desean pero que ninguno se anima a
iniciar
la paz esa actitud
si vamos a un cuadro donde el un eje x
coloquemos colocamos algo el título
inolvidable y en el eje y útil para
determinar qué efecto tienen esos estos
elementos que utilizamos para lograr la
paz pues encontramos esto los libros de
autoayuda se se ubican en ese punto cero
punto cero en esa posición y dependerá
de si acertó la persona en el tema de
autoayuda que necesitaba
las tarjetas personalizadas serán en un
momento olvidables y también un poco
útiles
está comprobado científicamente que
cuando escribimos a mano nuestras
conexiones cerebrales son más fuertes
y lo que escribimos lo interiorizamos
más
las armas
son inolvidables y no son útiles
la universidad de washington hizo un
estudio en el año 2016 y determinó que
en el mundo murieron 668 personas al día
en el año 252 mil personas por armas de
fuego
el paño de la paz se ubica en ese punto
útil
e inolvidable
desde desde su raíz desde su carisma
esta es mi ciudad
cali
el capital del valle del cauca la
tercera ciudad más grande de colombia la
capital del sur occidente colombiano muy
conocida porque la capital mundial de la
salsa
como toda ciudad
tiene sus oportunidades tiene sus
problemas y más aún cuando perteneces a
un país que por más de 50 años ha
intentado
y solucionar un conflicto armado
sin embargo esto no me limito a desafiar
una creencia la creencia de actuar
localmente pensando globalmente yo actúe
globalmente pensando localmente
para terminar
quiero nombrar ese esta frase citar esta
frase de barack obama
que la mencionado durante uno de sus
discursos cuando
reconocía que hay un problema en su país
y que había que hacer algo
si hay una sola cosa que podemos hacer
si hay una sola persona que podemos
salvar tenemos la obligación de
intentarlo
para terminar quiero que recuerden esta
frase por el resto de sus vidas
amar es reconocer
es comprometerse es estar en paz muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]